good good evening distinguished guests
dear ladies and gentlemen it is my very
great honor to be in this very extreme
very very steam company which in many
ways in fact is a Nobel Prize of field
prize Factory
and as you are sure very well aware we
are faced today with ever-increasing
societal economic environmental health
challenges in fact some of the themes
here we're about that and of course it
is only natural that research is
directed towards finding solutions to
these challenges that will of course
lies a sustainable future however it
must be pointed out and then believe and
from what I hear I'm very much largest
speaking to a converted audience here is
that long term wise in fact true
sustainability for Europe and the world
lies in supporting the best ideas the
top scientists and the top innovators in
there okay perhaps has been pointed out
tractable and realistic but curiosity
driven and bottom-up research because
that is the only path to ensure
relevance and leadership in the world
today where one can easily envisage that
due to ongoing and in fact accelerating
revolutions in science and engineering
the world will change
proportionally looking perhaps in the
next 30 years more than this change in
the last 300 or 3000 or 30,000 years it
is actually really really exciting time
and this is where in fact the importance
of ERC is extremely extremely important
important so this is yes where EFC steps
in a science driven funding mechanism
committed to high risk high gain
research funding targeting new and
emerging issues ERC made the european
research system
much more attractive place for top
researchers and consequently adverse
brain drain Europe and in fact formed a
Brain Gain in all around Europe and some
country countries in particular there's
a great great success it is actual also
very important to commend the great
effort ERC has investing closing the gap
between research and innovation and some
of the talks here been very very
interesting indeed so the proof of
concert for example grants enabled to
delivering the frontier research results
to the market much more efficiently than
has been the case before wherever for
the newly introduced again introduced
synergy grants ERC provides
opportunities for the immense progress
of frontier knowledge in this regard and
going to the creation not a bit more i'm
very proud to say that croatia got it
it's new now a signature grant holder
and free vitoli chand in a pub in and
also i'm actual very person proud of
this as i used to be the head of an
institute research institute before
became a secretary in croatian who in
fact would eva tallish from germany to
croatia very very happy about this
reverse no offense to germany but we're
happy about that this in fact this in
fact brings me to the upcoming Croatian
presidency of the council in the first
half of next year and also it emphasizes
its priorities and in Croatia will of
course continue negotiations of the
remaining outstanding issues in relation
to the main programs in particular in
relations to horizon Europe
these include primarily openness of the
programs to third countries countries
like you know Switzerland Israel UK
don't mention breaks that yes okay so
and as well as the budget again this
will be to a very large extent an issue
an issue during the Croatian presidency
also we want to make synergies of
horizon 2020 with structural funds as
flexible as possible including if
possible and synergies with the ERC
you know still excellence and other and
and further on in fact a key theme of
the Croatian presidency will be
promoting the importance of rain
circulation defined as a two-way flow of
highly skilled people as opposed to the
brain drain which Croatia and a lot of
us say the EU thirteen conscious face in
other countries face in particular the
focus of the creation presidents will be
on how to address the negative influence
and how to maximize the benefits of
brain circulation striving towards as
much as possible towards a symmetric
mobility and reduce the heterogeneity of
research systems in the different
individual countries so we want to focus
on enhancing a balanced and fair brain
circulation Europe for the benefit of
all these parts and the Union as a whole
we hope to set clear targets for this
upcoming period in that regard we
strongly believe that it is in fact
largely the responsibility of the
individual nations for the brain
circulation as opposed to brain drain
and that the quality of the national
research systems the hydration systems
is crucial to attracting and retaining
high quality researchers with that in
mind
so basically dampen should not be on
just horizon Europe how that will help
and want you though and one main reason
one crucial reason why allow this EU 13
countries including unfortunate Croatia
are not as successful as the all the
members the year fifty ones is the fact
of the individual national system so
it's not it is only a question of
funding partially but actually also a
question of very outdated higher
education science system some of them
which are not changed much from the 19th
century even so with that in mind I mean
Croatia
is currently working toward introducing
a new and far-reaching act in higher
education and science
with the goal to enable more
international competitive science focus
on project-based access in particularly
our seas in fostering international
mobility in creating conditions where
the academia interacts much more easier
with the high-tech economy than has been
the case so far
accordingly the creation position paper
emphasizes the first pillar of the
future program including increase of
funding for ERC so from the position of
a small country in a new country and
unfortunately a modest innovator only we
can appreciate the importance of
increasing investment in research and
development so we hope to see even more
funds available in the following program
period for horizon particularly for ERC
we are proud to say that we are so press
well free our seas in from fp7 with
five-year sea grants on horizon 2020 so
far three in the past few in the past
few months only and I'm very happy to
point out that out of this basically a
TRC is a large majority a woman in fact
I think six out of the eight so so very
very proud of that the number of course
should be much much higher and Croatia
in in addition to the as I said the new
axe laws of the to change the safe to
higher education introducing numerous
measures to increase in participation
horizon 2020 with special measures on
increasing and supporting DRC grantees
you know given additional funds
additional you know permanent positions
and such would the idea is you know to
the best and give the most so I will end
with this and I would like to wish
professor jean-pierre bourguignon all
the best in this extremely important
work thank you very much
[Applause]
Thank You state secretary well now we're
really very delighted to welcome the new
commissioner
for research innovation education
culture and youth Maria Gabrielle and
we're really delighted that you're able
to come and join us here this evening at
the beginning of your mandate thank you
thank you very much dear president
bourguignon ladies and gentlemen
excellency it's a great honor for me to
be here I'm always impressed by the
talent that we have in Europe by the
good cooperation that we establish with
other partners in the world so it's a
real pleasure for me to be here this
night with with you as you already know
the new European Commission has taken
office this week and I'm really proud
I'm proud to be in charge of a portfolio
that has a strong focus on knowledge and
future-oriented policies a portfolio
that truly matters to our European
citizens at the same time contributing
to delivering on Europeans wider
objectives so today's events is a very
good way to start in this new capacity
and to be very honest I'm really very
glad with the change of the title of my
portfolio
so thank you very much
[Applause]
it was possible thanks to your
mobilization thanks to your very strong
messages but for me there is a very
strong significance because for us
Europeans the word that means values
content sense and believe me you can
count on my first support not only to
include research in the title of this
new portfolio but really really to rely
on you in order to tackle the main
European challenges in order to convince
every European citizen how much the
research frontier research is important
if you'd like to offer some common
answers to those challenges so the theme
of this event a sustainable future for
Europe the contribution of frontier
research is really highly topical as you
already know the first headline
initiative in this new commission is the
European Green Deal and as expressed by
our president from the lion we aim at
becoming the world's first climate
neutral continent by 2050 and to move
forward zero pollution environment but
that means at the same time that this
transition towards a competitive
sustainability is a great challenge and
opportunity that's why we need all the
brains all the ideas in this endeavor
and I count a lot on you because we all
know that the best investment in our
future I don't like to insist in our
present is the investment in our
researchers in our young people in our
innovators that's why education research
innovation and behavior change will be
key will be key if you'd like to
demonstrate our ability
to make the transition to a climate
neutral economy in a digital age
at the same time thank you very much
excellency for the strong message we are
counting on the next creation presidency
because it's very good to have ambitions
it's very good to have goals but now and
first we need to defend our budget the
budget for horizon Europe the budget for
European research council if you'd like
really to fulfill with concrete content
those ambitions and you already know we
started with another mobilizations three
four weeks ago there is for some for our
people some encouraging news coming from
the last days that's not my case it's
not acceptable for me any cut for
horizon Europe so we need to continue we
need to stay as mobilised as as possible
in order just to show that if you'd like
to tackle climate change to provide
answers for the digitalization if you'd
like to tackle the demographic changes
we need for that to invest in research
and innovation and that's why I count on
me I will stay very firm in this
endeavour because I fully believe that
horizon Europe framework program will
make maybe the most important
contribution and at the same time that's
our guarantee to spread successful
solutions across Europe we would like
really to see a horizon Europe program
which is a key enabler to accelerate the
pace of the societal transition in
synergies yes with other national and
European programs talking about
synergies yes it's a very beautiful
world my intention now and like really
to to count on you to it's to transform
those beautiful
intentions and towards in a concrete
actions with different tools we can
really achieve more and yes in horizon
Europe we have 35% for climate change
but my intention is really to cooperate
very closely with all the other
commissioners in order to contribute and
to show very clearly what is the
contribution of research for the answers
of those challenges and here in horizon
Europe European Research Council will
continue to have a very important role
to play in pursuing groundbreaking
frontier research radical new
technologies and disruptive research and
innovation are needed if you'd like to
fuel this required societal transition
yes we are really proud president
bourguignon the European Research
Council truly is a game changer it has
become the world's top funding agency
not only by the percentage of supported
scientific papers but for me what is
really important is to see how it is the
impact of ERC in generating scientific
excellence well known and whether it is
true highly cited top papers or Nobel
Prize winners here I know that we have
the honor to have some of them with us
and I already enjoy next week another
one so thank you very much we are really
very very proud of you and I'm of course
excited that such a European success
story falls within my limits and I'm
deeply committed to safeguarding diggs
success because on one side we don't
have so much European success stories we
are telling some of the people but my
answer is that no
we have success stories European success
stories but we need to promote them to
make them more visible and count on me
to popularize what you are doing and I
would like to say here that Europe as a
whole as a continent we need to
strengthen our position in order to
address the challenges in the future and
the in particular the sustainability
challenges so knowledged
develop through ERC projects will allow
us to understand the challenges at a
more fundamental level and will provide
us with future electrodes and innovation
that we currently do not foresee and let
there be no doubt bottom-up GRC funded
research also contributes to political
priorities we have already heard
examples here today on how GRC supported
frontier Research Projects make real
difference in the area of sustainability
challenges and the projects increase our
knowledge on sustainability thereby
contributing to a better understanding
of the problems we face and at the same
time you help us to increase our ability
to solve them
that's why clearly investing in frontier
research is an investment into the
future from cheer research has a great
potential to improve people's lives and
significantly accelerate efforts to
achieve the sustainable development
goals and address climate change and the
others come on our European challenges
so I would like also here to highlight
that other speakers present today
reflect the ERC global nature with
representatives from across the world
and the ERC's global standing is clearly
an asset for us for Europe it could pave
the way for more international
cooperation or sustainability issues on
common interest much of this has been
spearheaded by the ERC president
professor of bourguignon and this
evening I especially want to play to pay
tribute to the extraordinary work done
by you your leadership as president has
served to strengthen the excellent
results and reputation of ERC thank you
very much president thank you for your
energy for your vision for your
commitment and at the same time today is
a day to thank you for all you have done
before to pass the baton to Professor
Maurer Ferrari on the 1st January next
year I look very much to working with
all of you not only with the president
but all the others so in concluding I
would like to underline that curiosity
driven bottom-up research is essential
in addressing the many complex and
sometimes threatening challenges we are
faced with today and in the future
investing in the ERC is giving us hope
that some of the daring ideas funded
today will provide us with the solutions
we need for tomorrow's challenges so let
us whole support the groundbreaking
frontier research that holds promises
for the disruptive changes we need from
the future thank you very much
thank you very much commissioner so now
we're drawing to a close and I would
like to invite on stage our president
professor jean-pierre bourguignon to
deliver the closing remarks of this
event the Commissioner for innovation
research culture education and youth
yamaraja Gabrielle thank you very much
also Tommy
auntie Cheech for your engagement and
also telling us where Croatia will take
us I still remember the visit of your
Institute in Zagreb it was very
interesting and particularly a meeting
of course if a college is definitely
Croatian hero
she's a European hero I was very pleased
for with this session which had as you
understood several components of course
very important round table looking at
the problem from a global point of view
by the way during the round table you
notice that several people brought up
the issue that the solution is also in
very basic critical education so
actually your portfolio now you have the
two tools so you cannot miss that and I
was very pleased because usually when I
discuss with people that's one thing I
always bring up namely that of course
I'm a researcher my natural community is
the scientific community but I think we
should never forget the people who are
shaping the next generation namely the
teachers and from that point of view I
think this is something which to many
countries actually are neglecting and
really priority for education they
cannot be separated from priority for
research I appreciated very much the
both of you had a very fighting spirit I
think we
in a sense are in a moment where we know
there is not much time left for many
things and therefore the right decisions
have to be really made very quickly and
I'm sure that the scientific community
will be able to mobilize itself as it
did for example not so long ago when the
European front for strategic investment
which was certainly a great idea but it
was not a great idea to take away money
from myself structure reactions and ERC
but we managed to have this change so I
hope we continue with this same fighting
spirit jointly and because of course the
previous fight was jointly with actually
you know you probably know that with the
Commissioner Moyes but also
vice-president rojava
so it was interesting combination of
efforts and I think we succeeded in the
end so this isn't gentlemen it has been
I think a very great moment of listening
to high-level scientists I don't want to
finish without thanking our grantees who
came and contributed to show the
fantastic diversity and of course
quality of work they are doing also very
much explaining very clearly how really
curiosity-driven or passion-driven as
Sir Peter told us we should think speak
about is really very essential for the
future development and really that we
often as we were explained you you came
up you come up with the solution as a
researcher of a problem you never
thought you would be tackling so it is
something which happens often of course
you need a very open mind you need
sometimes also to be pushed or to be
confronted with people who just push
push you in a slightly different
direction but I think that's the whole
spirit of ERC and also the staff of the
agency is also very good at accepting
reorientation of projects when this is
needed and I think also since these are
very important I'm speaking at the
moment rain poured moment of conclusion
for this discussion you understand that
all your sea grants could not exist
without the strong
support by the european commission in
particularly having an agency which is
highly functional and therefore thank
you to everybody for the contributions
of tonight in particular to the people
who are extremely busy and on today
being here was really a very great gift
that we receive from them but at the
same time to everybody who came here so
I hope you can really help us for the
future you know there is some more
battles to fight but I'm sure you are
also in this fighting spirit we heard
tonight thank you very much
[Applause]